you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
when we look back on technology history
we often see great stories of human
innovation but sometimes there are those
little inventions of genius that slip
through the cracks of time for one
reason or another laser disks were one
of those inventions so we're all aware
of the compact disc a technology that
upon its release in 1982 was nothing
short of revolutionary unlike wax
records or cassette tapes CDs meant that
your music didn't get worn out when you
played it back the quality didn't
deteriorate over time so sound could now
be digitally stored forever and what
you've just been listening to is the
ultimate in recorded sound it will make
all conventional discs and cassette
systems obsolete it's dust proof scratch
proof digitally recorded red by laser
and it's called the compact disc
considering its quality and size the
compact discs most certainly will become
a part of our everyday lives in the
future and the lawn rents can become a
revolution just pop it in and play it to
balan relax enjoy the music what many
younger people may not realize today was
that the CD was actually based on an
earlier technology that was extremely
advanced for its time the laser disc a
home video format far superior in
quality than the VHS standard of the day
in this video we'll take a look at the
forgotten technology that started a
revolution let's begin so what is a
laser disc the laser disc was the first
commercial optical disc storage medium
it was basically the DVD of the late
1970s each movie disc was huge measuring
12 inches of 30 centimeters in diameter
these discs were played on laserdisc
players from manufacturers such as
Philips Magnavox and pioneer a record
player that produces beautiful sound and
pictures through my TV optical laser
scanner and Magna vision was the first
consumer product in our galaxy to use it
now that is an entirely new dimension in
entertainment
the technology for the laserdisc was
first developed in the late 1950s by
David Paul Greg he figured out how to
record digital information onto an
optical transparent foil while working
for gauze electro physics a Californian
company in 1968 Greg's patents were
purchased by music corporation America
and in 1972 the first demonstration of
the video disc took place after a
partnership with Philips corporation six
years later in 1978 the first
mass-produced
industrial laser disc player was
released its name was the MCA Disco
vision PR 7/8 - oh the disco vision bit
was later rebranded pioneer in North
America in the 1970's and early 80's
this unit was used by General Motors at
their dealerships as a source of
training videos and for presentation of
their new line of cars and trucks for
context 1978 was two years after the
introduction of the VHS VCR and four
years before the introduction of the CD
it was in the same year that the first
laserdisc home movie title was released
jaws from 1978 to 2001 there were over
30,000 titles released so how did they
work here's a 1978 video by music
corporation America showcasing some of
the technical basics this is a
microscopic photograph of the surface of
a video disc the creators you see are
really my new pits the information
source of the system on a typical
half-hour disc there may be as many as
14 billion of these tiny indentations a
beam of light focused down to one thirty
thousandth of an inch passes through the
plastic layer striking the pits which
interrupt the reflected beam
this on/off reflected beam is then
translated into electronic impulses each
of the 54,000 circular tracks is
equivalent to one television frame when
the optical reader head is programmed to
play the same track over and over again
a freeze-frame results there's another
remarkable thing about laser light it's
capable of carrying enormous amounts of
information simply because the light is
of such short wavelength
I'll show you let's assume this is the
information that you want to send out
over electromagnetic waves
here's a carrier of relatively long
waves that's the amount of information
it could carry
here's a carrier of much shorter
wavelength
see the long waves missed some of the
information while the shorter waves
carried much more of it in other words
the shorter the wavelength the more
information it can carry and the greater
detail and a laser beam is of such short
wavelength it can carry unbelievable
amounts of information I think it's
amazing that the thing worked at all
they were really pushing the boundaries
of the available technology at the time
because the laser dis look like a giant
CD you could be forgiven for thinking
that it's digital but actually the
signal was analog so how do the laser
discs compare to its main competitor VHS
well still images could be seen on laser
discs without wearing out a tape on a
rotating video drum unlike VHS systems
the discs also had a much longer
lifespan because there's no physical
contact needed to read tapes on the
other hand could easily be stretched and
walked it's only when you record from
one tape to another a few times that the
electronics have problems and the
imperfections thoughts show up this is
an original recording
the quality is really very good but
unlike broadcast machines the quality of
the second and subsequent generations
quickly deteriorates first the picture
gets less sharp
then the color stops fitting the picture
and the vertical lines get more ragged
then the sound quality deteriorates and
the color which is recorded separately
disappears
finally the picture and the sound break
up completely laser discs had almost
twice the horizontal resolution of
cassette tapes the discs could also
store multiple audio tracks which was
impossible on VHS this allowed for
extras such as directress commentary and
other bonus features very new at the
time but is now common practice for DVDs
okay so what about laser disburses DVDs
it has to be said that by the time the
DVD came around the laser discs had
already declined but when DVDs first
came out the high motion scenes and
movies often suffered from blockiness
due to digital encoding and compression
funnily enough since laser discs were
analog there was no digital compression
so sometimes laser discs were actually
preferred of course as DVD is improved
there was no competition
okay so almost at the end of this video
there's one question that you might be
asking and I asked myself why didn't lay
sir this take off it seemed like from
the mid 1980s to the early 2000s laser
discs would have had a clear run before
DVDs took over it was a technology that
was far superior to tapes so what
happened well firstly the discs were
heavy weighing about half a pound or a
quarter of a kilo each though also
cumbersome and more prone to damage if
mishandled and VHS tapes also because of
their size greater mechanical effort was
required to spin the discs at the
required speed this resulted in much
more noise generated than other media to
make things worse manufacturers refused
to market recordable laser disc devices
on the consumer market even though the
competing VCR devices could record onto
cassette this hurt sales worldwide
and probably the worst thing of all the
disks could only play 30 to 60 minutes
per side depending on the format so some
movies could require two or more disks
in most players when one side finished
you had to get up and manually flip it
over this all isn't to mention that a
movie title would sell for around $80 in
today's currency in summary even though
the laserdisc was promising the
inconvenient size the high cost of both
the players and discs and the inability
to record onto those discs all combined
to take a serious toll on sales making
it forever forgotten in the history
pages of Technology the last laserdisc
movie released in the US was in the year
2000 but interestingly enough laserdisc
players were made until the year 2009 so
there you have it the once promising
technology of the future that just
didn't quite make it to the mainstream
but still eventually led the groundwork
for the CD it's quite a little
interesting piece of technology history
and I thought I might as well share with
you guys alright thanks for watching
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it hit that subscribe
button if you've just done what across
this channel and I'll see you guys again
soon for the next video thanks guys have
a good one
cold fusion its new thinking
[Music]